thousands of people have fled their
homes in the central Philippine province
of Albay ahead of a possible volcanic
eruption but many say life in the shadow
of the volcano is something they've
become used to
Bonnie below has this report from near
the volcano
the central Philippine province of Albay
in a state of disaster on Friday
authorities went from Village to Village
at the foot of the moyon volcano to move
residents to temporary shelters away
from the threat of an eruption
scientists say they've observed an
increase in activity that could lead to
a dangerous explosion
we possible scenarios first is the 2014
scenario wherein there were only rock
falls or it could be like 2018 when
there was a major eruption
despite the warning areas around the
volcano aren't a no man's land yet myON
volcano that mountain behind me that's
shrouded in clouds is one of the most
active volcanoes in the Philippines it
threatens to erupt every few years now
this area is within its six kilometer
radius declared as a permanent danger
zone but thousands of people live here
some families have taken a day to weigh
up their options the delatorices are
getting ready to leave after the
government ordered evacuations we are
here
life in the evacuation Center isn't easy
we sleep on the ground there are cash
stipends but we don't get them right
away
says she's worried about their crops in
livestock but for the sake of her
children she's decided to go
we here in field of volcano rumbling
then last night the summit was glowing
my own volcano is part of their lives
but how can anyone get used to it they
ask when the choices of in between life
and death
Martin below Al Jazeera I'll buy the
Philippines
joining us live now from Aquino batan in
Albay Province so Barnaby what's the
very latest you can tell us then
yeah Carrie it has been raining on and
off here in Albay Province where my own
volcano is in the last 24 hours and
yesterday when we spoke with each other
uh the volcano was shrouded in clouds
and today again it's being obscured by
clouds although it's right behind me you
probably can't see it and this rain
could present a problem if it rains for
a number of consecutive hours and the
volcano starts to spew lava it could
create what's called a Lahar flow which
is a combination of rain water and the
lava forming wet volcanic materials
flowing down the slope of the volcano
and this mud flow is hot and dangerous
and a good um could destroy crops could
destroy properties and if there are
people still living in these danger
zones Villages within the vicinity of
the volcano their their lives are also
at risk State volcanologists say that
the volcano has entered a new eruptive
stage because the volcano has formed a
new lava Dome so whereas the previous
day within a period of 24 hours there
were 59 rockfall events in the last 24
hours there were 177 rockfall events and
again this is because there is now a new
lava dome last night as well the sky did
clear up for about an hour and so people
got to see dazzling orange glow at the
top of the volcano near the crater and
it may be dazzling to see but State
balkanologists say that this is a sign
of danger it means that temperature is
rising within the volcano which means
that there is heightened activity and
that's why alert level 3 is still raised
over Beyond volcano which means that
these heightened activities could lead
to a hazardous eruption and it could
happen today tomorrow within days within
weeks but it could also last months
Carrie Barnaby as you say extremely
dangerous so what of the people who are
living in and around the region itself
then
yeah so authorities have expanded
evacuation operations to include one
more kilometer away from the volcano so
there is a six kilometer radius around
the volcano that's called the permanent
danger zone now the extra one kilometer
Villages around this extra one kilometer
they're also being asked to evacuate
their homes so this could include more
than ten thousand families now but you
could understand the hesitation you saw
there in my piece there are families
that are hesitant to leave their homes
because they want to be able to
safeguard their properties they want to
be able to safeguard their livestock and
live in the evacuation dance centers can
be very difficult and just to illustrate
to you how difficult uh these
evacuations can be there is one family
right now in one evacuation center that
is holding awake so imagine that they
have to bring a dead body from their
Village to the evacuation Center so life
not very easy in these evacuation
centers and again this could last month
just as it did in 2018 Kerry
one of you though in Albay Province for
us there thank you